we're just on the cusp of incredible
changes
to sports entertainment and fan
experience
technology has evolved to the point
where we're interconnecting
technology with things like software
analytics
video and 5g imagine if there was
a 5g chip in a player's helmet
could you experience seeing from the
eyes of the quarterback
yes those things are real we had
opportunities to be all over
when building mercedes-benz stadium it
was critical to us
to stay right in the heart of atlanta to
ultimately be the heartbeat
of atlanta a stadium is just not a
building where sports games
happen it's about workforce development
it's about
education it's about community one of
the things that have been very clear to
us
during covet is the gap in broadband
access
we have worked with many venues where we
have enabled the technology
for school children to come and use that
technology free of charge so they can
participate in remote learning
technology
is enabling these venues to help in ways
that we haven't thought of before
you can't come to mercedes-benz stadium
without knowing that 18t businesses here
they're a part of bringing three million
people through the doors they're part of
the 53 major events we do
think about the changing nature of
venues and the proliferation of 5g
it's amazing how we can connect fans
and the venue to greater atlanta they're
impacting our lives
if we look five years down the road how
do i see this stadium
and where is the community it's a
community that's empowered
that has technology at its core it's a
community that has come
[Music]
together